there are two ways to solve for the
square root of a number we can either
use a calculator of course everybody
would love to use this option and the
other way is to solve it manually
manually - we can solve it in two
different ways
one by using the prime factorization
method which we have already seen we
split the number to its prime factors
and then choose one number from each
pair the other method which we will look
at in this video is called the long
division method the name sounds fancy
but don't worry if you follow the steps
given in this video you will never go
wrong but why can't we just use prime
factorization every time well if the
number is large it will take us a lot of
time to reduce it to its prime factors
and the chances of going wrong are very
high
hence prime factorization is useful only
for small numbers and for large numbers
we can use the long division method
let's solve a couple of examples to
understand how the long division method
works look at the number 8281 if we have
to reduce this number to its prime
factors we would first have to think of
all the divisibility rules and so on and
that would take us a lot of time so for
such large numbers we use the long
division method the first thing we need
to do in the long division method is to
draw lines like this a line on top and
align to the left of the number when you
draw a line on top of the number
remember to leave some space above the
number once you're done drawing these
lines you're ready for the first step
the first step is to mark pairs of
digits from the unit's end the unit's
end is the number one so we mark pairs
of digits from right-hand side this
becomes our first pair from the right
the number 81 we continue to mark pairs
till we cover all digits of the number
the next pair will be 82 so the first
step was simple we just mark pairs from
the right which gives us 2 pi
is 82 and 81 now we look at the first
pair from the left which is 82 in the
second step we have to find the perfect
square which is equal to or lower than
82 since 82 is not a perfect square we
choose the perfect square lower than 82
the perfect square just lower than 82 is
81 even 64 is a perfect square
lower than 82 but remember we always
choose the one which is closest we know
that 9 squared equals 81 we just found
out the most crucial number it's the
number 9 9 is basically the square root
of the closest perfect square we write
the number 9 here to the left of the
number this was actually the most
important step of the long division
process to find the first number the
next step is one of the easiest steps
but it's a step where most the students
get confused the step says multiply
above and add below but what do we
multiply and what do we add it is the
same number 9 let's focus on multiplying
above first we multiply 9 with 9 and
write the product here so the 9 you're
multiplying is written on top now let's
come to add below we add 9 with 9 and
write the sum underneath 9 plus 9 gives
us 18 we multiply the same number with
itself
above and wrote the product here and we
added the same number with itself and
wrote the sum here
remember when we multiply or add we're
doing the operation with the same digit
in this case it's 9 so we have completed
three steps first we found the pairs
from the right second we found the
perfect square and wrote a square root
here third we multiplied above and add
it below if you observed it well you
could see that I have left some space
next to the sum of nines that space is
kept for
box so we draw an empty box here and
inside this box we will be writing some
digit our next aim is to find this digit
the next three steps are super simple we
just subtract the product from the
number above it the product we got was
81 the number above it is 82 we subtract
81 from 82 and get 1 and then we get the
next pair down the next pair is 81 so we
write it next to 1 then we draw the same
box above and below above we draw it
next to 9 and below we draw it under the
original box the digits contained in
each of these boxes are the same the
next step according to me is the most
interesting step of the long division
method we use trial and error to find
the digit in the boxes we look for the
product of two numbers which gives us
181 this is how the product should look
what number do you think we can write in
the boxes to get 181 as our product
remember the digits in both the boxes
have to be the same yes 181 multiplied
by 1 gives us 181 so we have found the
digit in the boxes
it's 1 after we find this digit we go
back to the third step and follow the
same procedure multiply above so we
write a 1 and a 1 in these two boxes and
get the product of 181 and one as 181
then we add below we add 1 281 and get
182 then we subtract the product from
the number above it so we subtract 181
from 181 and get a 0 the moment we get a
0 here and there are no more pairs left
we are done
but wait where's the square root of 8281
well it's the number you got on top it's
91 the square root of 8281
is 91 trust
me it's not difficult it's just a little
lengthy let's review what we just did we
marked pairs from the unit's end which
gave us two pairs 82 and 81 then we
choose a perfect square which is equal
to or lower than the leftmost pair 82 we
found out that 81 is the closest square
we write at square root to the left then
we multiply above 9 x 9 equals 81 and
added below 9 plus 9 equals 18 and with
18 we leave space for one more digit
then we reach the three simple steps
first we subtract the product 82 minus
81 gives us 1 second we get the next
pair down and then we draw the same box
above and below which will contain the
same digit as the original box and to
find the digit in the boxes we use trial
and error and get 181 x 1 as 181 so the
number in the box
will be 1 after we find the number in
the box we go back to the third step we
multiply above 180 1 x 1 gives us 181
then we add the same digit below 180 one
plus one equals 182 then we subtract the
product 181 - 180 1 gives us 0 and since
there is no pair left we stop and get
the square root as 91 remember inside
the two lines we always subtract an
outside we always add to get a better
idea see the second part of this video
in which we have solved for the square
root of another number using this same
procedure
you
[Music]
you